[Music]
china has been on a global vaccine
delivery drive since the early days of
the pandemic
and beijing gave that effort a boost
amid growing concerns over omicron a new
coronavirus variant that seems far more
transmissible than others
the pledge came after china said it
shipped 1.8 billion vaccines to 120
countries i'm very grateful of this is
this huge donation to africa china was
very interested in using its vaccines to
advance a number of geopolitical goals
and the u.s has its own goals too i
think the u.s based on its trials is
very competent in its vaccine they feel
like it's important for them to be in
lead donating
less than a week after chinese president
xi jinping's pledge president biden also
promised to send 9 million extra
vaccines to africa i'm keeping the
promise that america will become the
arsenal of vaccines china got out ahead
of the u.s in shipping its doses around
the world but the biden administration
has said it's donated more and now
omicron could challenge both superpowers
vaccine diplomacy efforts
but first how is china able to get a
head start
as early as may of 2020 beijing declared
that it would make its homegrown
vaccines a global public good and it was
able to make that promise because it
started vaccinating its own population
with its doses a few months later
then by september china started shipping
its vaccines abroad the us on the other
hand began sending doses nearly a year
later
china was faster because its vaccines
were made with traditional methods and
not with advanced genetic technology
like the first vaccines that were
approved in the u.s
this also meant chinese doses were
easier to ship since they didn't need to
be stored in ultra-cold temperatures
plus state enterprises jumped in to help
with the vaccine supply chain working
with 19 countries to manufacture doses
locally being the first is very
important because there's an element of
stickiness so in some ways makes it more
difficult for the recipient countries to
buy vaccines from other countries
afterwards bonnie lynn is a senior
fellow at the center for strategic and
international studies a bipartisan
foreign policy think tank she's been
tracking china's vaccine diplomacy and
found that of the 1.1 billion doses
beijing agreed to ship 96 were
designated as sales and the rest as
donations
china said its vaccines would be offered
at a fair and reasonable price and lynn
says this direct-to-consumer
relationship gives beijing leverage one
of the things that china does gain is a
bit more influence
over the recipient countries and china
was able to use its vaccines to
encourage countries to
issue statements in support of china for
instance paraguay said it was approached
by unofficial chinese brokers who
offered to purchase vaccines from china
on its behalf in return for breaking
diplomatic ties with taiwan it declined
the offer and china said the incident
was malicious disinformation
countries in the indo-pacific region
have also been receiving chinese doses
and that's grabbed the attention of
another vaccine donor the united states
has focused quite a bit of our efforts
in trying to provide vaccines in that
region in order to push back against
whatever influence china may have
and the u.s has been trying to lead by
donating its vaccines to poorer
countries and a majority of them are
from pfizer and biontech and moderna
which have high efficacy rates against
the original variant of the virus
compare that with china's vaccines
a study by bahrain and colombia
university also found that the death
rate for sino farm recipients was three
times higher than those inoculated with
pfizer
lin says the efficacy of chinese
vaccines may have dented beijing's
efforts to gain influence
a number of countries are
much more cautious now about taking
chinese vaccines and there are
increasing questions of why does china
need to have such a stringent zero
tolerance and many suspect it's because
of its lack of confidence in its own
vaccines
and now the emergence of a new
fast-spreading variant has triggered a
wave of fresh restrictions and omicron
is forcing leaders to speed up
vaccination drives around the world
individuals who talk within the
administration are really concerned like
unless we get everyone vaccinated new
variants will crop up i also think
there's been a fair amount of pressure
on the administration to do more
um to help with the donation and to help
lead a lot of the world efforts in about
a week of omicron being declared a
variant of concern by the who but the
u.s and china made pledges to ship more
vaccines
it's about what can we be done
collaboratively to try and bring the
pandemic to heal and i think just from
what we've seen so far especially with
this new variant that just becomes more
urgent but those efforts also rely on
how current vaccines respond to omicron
and when boosters could be available to
poorer countries a hong kong university
study found two doses of the sinovac
vaccine do not produce enough antibodies
to fight against a new variant
meanwhile pfizer and biontech said that
initial lab tests showed that two doses
were significantly less efficacious at
blocking infection but a third dose
neutralized omicron and moderna said a
third dose of its vaccine increased
immune responses against the new variant
so while both superpowers compete to
lead with vaccines it may ultimately
come down to how effective the doses are
against new emerging variants
[Music]
you